welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am once again Jesse dalamore filling in
for David while he is not here to do the
videos
[Laughter]
uh right now we are facing a budget
battle we are facing a debt ceiling
increased battle that Republicans are
making hay over they are making trying
to score political points in an effort
to again create chaos and as much of it
as they can Jim shudo had a guy named
Dusty Johnson that's apparently his real
name Dusty Johnson republican from South
Dakota on and Jim shudo is doing a
valiant job a noble effort here
attempting to get Congressman Dusty
Johnson to just name one one single
program that he wants to put on The
Chopping Block to cut in an effort to
save the budget or whatever he gives him
multiple times multiple chances to do
this and the guy just flat out refuses
using some lame excuse about not wanting
to negotiate in public and I'm not going
to negotiate on TV the same thing we're
hearing Kevin McCarthy say
but it's very easy if you want to be a
leader you want to be a congressman you
want to be someone who's in this budget
battle making responsible choices about
America and the spending of taxpayer
dollars you should be able to name at
least one program that you think needs
to be revamped relative to spending
watch this
so first on the budget demands of of
your party here what specific programs
are you putting on the table to cut
well that's not how a negotiation works
and in fact the law says that the
president needs to step forward with a
budget first his team is going to miss
their February deadline they say they're
not even going to get that done until
March so here's what I think is step one
today we need to have the president and
the speaker in the same room that's
going to happen and we need to have
President Biden agree that he will
negotiate Over The Reckless spending
that our country has been engaged in but
as you know the debt ceiling relates to
budgets already passed by congresses
including with Republican votes what are
the positions because a negotiation as
you know involves if you want to call it
that involves two sides presenting their
positions can you name a single uh
program that Republicans would be
willing to cut money from to make a deal
but see I think that's ridiculously
unfair and here's why the credit card
bill comes to our family we have maxed
out our credit cards now of course
listen we're going to pay that credit
card bill we're legally obligated to do
so but rather than force all of the onus
on the Republicans which I know you all
love to do what a responsible reasonable
and sensible family would do is sit down
together
[Music]
that's the law the law puts the onus on
Congress in the nation to pay its bill
but please go ahead is there a program
that you can name that you personally
would be willing to see money cut from
well yeah there are lots of programs but
that but the point is I'm not going to
negotiate against the Republican party
on CNN
the only thing that we're asking for
today is for President Biden to be
responsible sensible and reasonable and
being willing to come to the table and
negotiate so Mr thumb with ears Dusty
Johnson refuses to answer even one
single program and his little his cute
little family analogy it just doesn't
hold water
family can't print money
budgets it's not a one-to-one comparison
and anyone who acts like it is is
pulling the wool of your eyes about how
simplistic it is
it's a complex macro economic system we
have here and budgets aren't like well I
got a mortgage I got a credit card bill
and I got my grocery bill and we'll just
it's not how it works and he knows it
Mr thumbs with ears knows it
it is it is disingenuous to say the
least